Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
just checking it on you.
I'm just checking it on.
You Do da Duda Iowa.
Got One more fucking day before I fucking
go home. One more day in the film.
I still got three more after this,
but I get to go home and
see my little daughter.
They're very excited about
that. Um, and by the way,
I asked the director if it's okay
if I tell you what movie it is,
cause I never know, you know, do you leak
out information? He said it was cool.
So the movie's called
Front Runner Front Rado and
it stars Hugh Jackman and uh,
directed by Jason Reitman.
Okay, there you go. So, oh,
freckles has a little part in there.
Don't blink your eyes,
you might miss me. But uh, that
is what I am working on out here.
And um, every time I go down
to set, I'm telling you,
they show me something that they shot
and it looks really, really fucking cool.
So I'm very excited to be in a,
in this movie here.
But uh, yeah, so I got
one day, one a I like,
I got one scene today site and
I'm the first one out of the gate.
That's about as good as it gets.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes you the first
scene and the last scene,
but you get to see everybody else act and
everything like that. And that's cool,
right? The only thing that's bad about
being there the entire fucking day is for
whatever reason, um, when
you're on a movie set,
you just eat like a fucking,
I don't even know why.
You don't even know why you're eating.
You're just sitting there going,
why am I eating right now?
Just standing around and all of a sudden
they bring around some fucking, uh,
oh Halloween's coming up here.
Some fucking Halloween cookies.
They start eating like Erin in the
fifth grade, literally eating it,
looking at another adult
who's also eating, getting
you both say the same time.
But the fuck are we doing?
Um,
I've actually been pretty good on this
shoot and the food's been awesome. So, uh,
and I did lay off the Halloween cookies
and I'm doing my fucking catio today.
But in a professional,
God dammit,
you guys all know what a
freckle booze bag bag am, right?
You all know how I can't lay off the
booze. Um, I've been doing it man,
70 fucking days. So a, I don't know,
think on day 73 already be 20%
of the year already have that in.
I might go a year, I might go a
year. I might fucking bows tonight.
I don't know. Who knows? It's
exciting. It's an exciting time.
You think that world series game
last night was fucking riveting?
That was, that was a joke compared
to watching me try to walk by a bar.
Um, I was on set last night
so I didn't get to, I saw, uh,
it was three
to one and then,
uh,
we were shooting the final thing and I
checked the score and I saw was three to
three is like, Holy Shit.
The Astros came back and um,
we ended up wrapping and uh,
it was like five to three.
Houston.
Yeah.
So I, you know, we go down there,
we get out of our fucking
clothes and all that shit.
We had get back into the regular
clothes to head back to the hotel,
everything shut down here.
And me and another actor went into the,
this bar that we saw that was open and uh,
try and get something to eat.
I think it was like after 12 at that
point was gonna slip tickets around the
area that we're staying at.
And uh,
we walked into the bar and saw that
it was five to five. I was like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
Well, maybe it was seven to five.
Seven to five.
Yeah.
The last I saw it was five to three
Astros' and in the time it took me to get
off set, jump in the van and head
back, it became seven to five Astros.
And I was like,
what the fuck happened?
I'm missing one of the greatest
world series games probably ever.
And um, so we go in there and we
asked the guy behind the bar, right.
You know, and the guy's like, he's
like, sorry, fellows. The fucking,
I can't even explain how
high this guy's voice was.
I Dunno if he was in the middle of
transitioning or whatever. I have no idea.
But it was like,
it was like Michael Jackson
level high inexplicably,
and the guy had stubble on his face.
I don't get it right.
Um, you look like a giant, like marionette
puppet and he's gone. Sorry fellows.
If you want [inaudible] you gotta go.
So fortunately this guy with the
high pitch voice told us where to go.
We ended up going all the
way down the street and uh,
like four or five blocks down and
it was really cold, uh, for Atlanta.
I thought he meant I'm sitting with a
little fucking sweatshirt and we went down
and found this bar that was still open
and we get in there, it's seven to five.
And as we walk in the door,
the Dodgers hit a home run,
I think to make it seven to six.
Okay.
They're only down by running. It's
like, you've gotta be kidding.
This is unbelievable.
And um,
unfortunately the game ended day.
I was sitting there because I wanted the
Astros to tie it up cause I want more,
more baseball. I want to see a, I want
to see a seven game series here. But uh,
I wanted the Dodgers to tie it
up cause I was hoping, you know,
I wasn't going to bed.
I was fucking wired.
I was hoping to get like
15 innings of baseball,
but congratulations to the Astros.
You know,
and things are getting a
little chippy out there.
I guess they're imitating some guy in the
Dodgers. That guy with the Blue Mohawk,
I don't know anybody's fucking name.
I guess he flips the bat and sticks his
tongue out so they're like, oh yeah,
well we're going to flip the bat.
We're going to stick our tongues out.
These are adult males, everybody, um,
stupid shit ever. But it's
been a, a incredible series.
So I'm hoping game three,
I'll actually be, uh,
I'll be home and I can sit down and
watch it. Now watch game three will suck.
You know what I mean? The pictures
dull, not even a good one.
They believe stranded base
runners. Um, and that's it.
That's all the fuck I got. I don't know
what to tell you. I'm just been, um,
working like a maniac. So I mean
the first scene tonight, uh, today,
which is great because,
um,
I'm actually going to do a
little promotion here. Um,
there's a 30 for 30 coming out,
an arguably one of the greatest,
if not the greatest entertainer of all
time and wrestler of all time ric Flair,
the ric flair,
30 for 30 is coming out and they're
having a premiere tonight and uh,
I'm going to go to it and I think
ric flair is going to be there.
So I'm going to go a little Jim Norton
here and try to get my picture cause I've
had a Twitter photo up on my,
uh,
whatever they buy Twitter accounts since
then. That was taken in June of 2014.
I still remember, I got
to meet him, talk to him.
He was the coolest fucking dude
ever was telling stories and uh,
just an awesome guy. So I'm hoping
that tonight I can update my photo.
I'll call that be haven't updated it in
three years because it was a ric flair
photo. Hopefully I can update it again
with another one. Um, and if I don't,
who gives a shit?
I get to watch the ric flair 30 for 30,
which everybody should watch.
I don't care what's going on in your life.
I don't care if your wife's going
like maybe third time together.
We go to the pumpkin patch.
[inaudible] you got to say,
lady, this is one. I'm not
doing the Tivo want this one.
I'm going to watch live
fucking what do I lie? Right?
You got to see this one live.
And um,
how do you, how do you wrap up
ric flair story in 30 minutes.
Yeah.
Is that what it means? Right.
30 stories, 30 minutes long.
They've already done way more than 30, so
they should, you know, I already saw Dan,
the Dan Marino football life and that
was 30 minutes like with commercials or
something like that was her day should
have been at least 90 minutes. Um,
how much the game has changed
and how much the game had the change.
And how did it had it be dead to become
borderline illegal to cover a receiver
past, you know, your
first little, you know,
two yard chuck or whatever you're allowed
to do. Now all of that had to happen.
NFL had to try to go global and
try to get all these fucking,
you know, half fans by,
by running up the scores.
All of that had to fucking happen for
Dan Marino's records that stood for 30
years to start the fall. That's
all I'm saying. You know,
that should have been 90 minutes.
No, I guess you can't do that.
Cause then all the other legendary
players who'd be like, well,
how come my we Joey
dirty 90,
he sticks his Toga,
flips the bat and then
they'd get all fucking upset.
I did things too, you know. So anyways,
I'm looking forward to that
and um, I dunno, and that's it.
Other than that, I'm going out of
my mind, uh, being stone sober,
remembering every fucking
waking moment of the day. Um,
every day that I'm sober,
I'm reminded why I drank.
You know, I, I got to go to an AA meeting.
I got to hear people talk
positively about being sober.
Cause I gotta be honest with you,
I don't fucking get it.
And when I fucking lay off the booze,
all it does is make me want to try drugs.
You know?
I never smoke weed. I don't smoke. I'm not
into it. I just don't, I'm not into it.
But then if I don't drink everyone
they know a couple of times a month,
I'm just like, I got to fucking do
something to break up the monotony.
I have such a respect for
these straight edge people.
I don't know how they do it.
Okay.
Can I tried to tell me about being sober?
He goes, you know, you don't understand.
Is that like, you know, alcohol kills.
I haven't seen endorphins.
I don't know what it is that actually
makes you feel good about your life.
He goes, I don't drink. I'm actually,
I don't need it. I don't need a bill.
I'm like high on life, you know? And
I was just looking at him. I was just,
I couldn't help but think
you're full of shit.
No you're not. You know, when you're
high on life, when you're a kid,
you know, and you never throw out your
back and your shoulders not fucked up.
You don't have a psychotic nerve issue.
Your feet don't hurt.
He just get out of bed.
You're brand new,
you're jumping around the fucking
house doing cartwheels and shit,
running around. Hey, let's
go in the living room.
You just get up and you'll
run to the other room. Then
you're high on life. Yeah,
you don't have any credit
card debt, right? You know,
got a lady in your life going to wish
they didn't have a date night, right?
None of that bullshit. Then you
can be high on that. You on life.
Then you know what happens. Uh, you
know what happens? You become an adult,
all right? And all of a sudden
you started understanding why,
why it is that technically,
you know what I mean?
If you live in down on the equator,
you actually standing sideways,
okay? And why you don't go
flying off the fucking plan.
You start to understand it.
It's the weight,
the weight of the universe being on
this thing that's fucking spin it right.
And all this fucking debt you're fucking
accumulate and it's all coming down on
you. And the holidays coming up right
on the holidays. Fun Anymore, Huh?
Do you get into the Christmas spirit the
way you got to start growing around and
fucking seeing everybody and
getting on a fucking plane.
Watch it some Douche bag
after they just said,
only one thing per person
in the overhead compartment.
Stick three fucking bags up there.
You know what I mean?
And that's when the stewardess
comes by and she just goes,
can I get you something? Could you like
something to drink? It's like, yeah, lady.
You know those little
bottles of booze you have?
How many of you think you
could carry in both your arms?
Why don't you stuff a few in your fucking
breezier over there and bring them
over here so I can get to
this goddamn flight? Right.
Um, or maybe, you know, maybe you
still enjoy that time of year.
It's that time of year when you could say,
look at that.
I was just singing a Christmas song
when I was still in the fucking was that
headphone as a beer commercial
head for the mountains.
That taste is smooth and it's Busch beer.
Busch beer.
I love how they have the balls to do a
commercial now as if their beer tastes
good. Everybody knows
that. Busch Beers for,
that's what that's like when you're hung
over and you want to get back in the
game. You know that
said, you know, Cook me.
Let me fucking slit your fucking eyelids.
Cause you were all swollen up
from the booze the night before.
And that's what that bears, let's put
Busch beer and all those fucking beers.
Cores, light, Busch, Busch light.
All of those fucking beers are when
you drank so hard the night before.
You know,
and you just don't have an opinion not
to drink the next day and you need to get
back in the game. It's the cortisone
shot of alcohol. That's what it is.
It's fucking stupid
fucking commercials with the guy
standing next to a damn river.
What does that all about?
To let me know how watered down that
fucking Cannop pisses that I'm going to be
drinking. But God bless you because
it still gets me fucked up. Um,
anyways. I don't know. Do I need
therapy? I don't know what it is.
I think I just need to
get home. Um, so anyways,
um, yeah, I just been going on in my
mind here, unless I'm down on the set,
if I'm just fucking hanging
out and it keeps saying,
I keep threatening to myself that I'm
going to go down to the college football
hall of fame,
but I don't think I'm going to make it
again today because I got to go the fuck
an elliptical burn off all
the food I ate yesterday.
I didn't do bad. I ate the fish
yesterday and I got to tell you,
the catering on this movie has been out
fucking standing. It's been delicious.
You know,
I dunno what,
what catering has gone to another
level since I started doing my, uh,
my three lines per movie acting career.
You know,
why don't they have awards for that?
For people like me on movies,
you know,
they,
they are best supporting actor.
Right.
But you mean you still gotta be
like a major part of the movie?
What about people like me? Where's
my award? I think that my award,
just an awards show. They should
do that. Just have it on youtube.
And they just had,
right.
You have a host nobody's heard of and a
bunch of actors you can't fucking name,
you know, and then you
let people vote, you know,
best two lines in a movie for 2017.
And uh, I dunno, whatever
awards you, you win.
It's like made out of chocolate or
something. You eat it or something.
I don't know what it is. Maybe it's
a little, it's a shot of the flask.
I don't know. I don't pretend to
understand these fucking things. Anyways,
guess what I'm doing next week? Everybody,
other than seeing my beautiful family,
spending every fucking second with them,
um,
is I am going to be playing the surf
Baldwin ballroom, sorry, in Iowa.
And this is where, uh, you
know, uh, uh, buddy Holly,
the big bopper and Richie
Valens all did their last show.
It's a little fucking more, but,
you know, but I want to go there.
I want to see it right.
And I'm flying right into the same airport
that they took off from and crashed.
And everybody's going, dude, what
the fuck? And it's like they,
they had ice on their wings.
That's what happened.
That's why they crashed that
in an experienced pilot.
And they had ice on the wings
and they didn't have the,
they didn't have the technology
back then, the spray, the chemicals.
So I'm going to go out on a limb and
say that I'm going to be all right. Um,
so anyways,
I'm going to be doing that
on a Thursday of next week.
And then Friday, Saturday, I'm in one of
my favorite goddamn cities in the world.
Milwaukee, Wisconsin. All right. And, uh,
Dean del Ray's going to be
doing the Thursday one and
then I got forsee and Bard
.
Nick,
yeah.
In Milwaukee for Z.
Bart,
nick and myself and one of
my favorite cities ever.
And, uh, I have to somehow try to
maintain being sober. I'm going to do it,
I'm going to do it, but I don't know
how much fucking longer I can go.
I got 70 days in.
All right.
You know what it is.
I know when I have that neck strength
that I'm just going to be on again for
another two fucking years.
That's what I'm hoping.
What I can do is I'm going just what
I'm going to do when I come back,
when I returned after this injury,
right?
When I make my return to the big leagues
of Booze, I would like to fucking,
I would like to boos the way I smoke
cigars now cause I got that under control.
Like I smoke a cigar like
once every fucking three
weeks or something like that.
That's how, right. Right. 12 to
15 a year. I'm so full of Shit.
I've smoked more than that this year, but
whatever, I at least I make an attempt.
Okay. The third base coach with
the cigars is holding people up.
All right?
But that fucking lunatic with the booze
is just waving me around every time.
Um, I don't know. I
gotta be honest with you.
Having a is a great way to fucking
not drink. You know what I mean?
You can't just sit there and getting
drunk when you have a kid in the house.
And plus even if you do like a moron,
the next morning your kid's going to
wake up at like seven in the morning and
then I'll give a fuck about a hangover.
Um,
so I guess it's just one, I'm on the road.
I don't know what it is or maybe
I just like booze and you know,
it's all of that shit. I really
enjoy it. I miss it. You know,
I think I'm going to sober dial
my fucking my booze itself.
Um, anyway, so I'm going to be doing that.
And then I go up to Green Bay and uh,
and then that Monday night Boba bubble
though to go to green bay as a Monday
night football game that I was going to
go to with [inaudible] and Bart. Nick,
I'm on, you know, I can't
even say, unfortunately,
I got to get back to do my last
three days on the movie. And, um,
so I can't make that one.
But Jesus Christ,
if you're not going to go to Lambeau
field, it's a pretty good excuse, right?
Cause you're going to be in a great
fucking movie starring Hugh Jackman called
front runner. There'll be coming out
in 2018 please tell all your friends,
please go to the movie
theaters and go see it. Um,
who knows if the schedule changes, maybe
I'll get to go, but I think versus the,
and partner could still gonna go.
Um, and that's it. Other than that,
I don't think I have anything left
to tell you other than my shoulders
completely fucked up again.
Um,
I turned the corner with
my rotator cup and um,
that I went too far.
I don't know if it's cause I did depths
or I tried to do a pull up with one of
those fucking assist
bands, things, you know,
I tried to do, I just pushed it too far
and then I got to start all over again.
It's fucking frustrating.
How are you going to do? He
can't do it. Hey, you know,
it's fucking annoying.
Two years,
say ag nerve last year and I got
my fucking shoulder, you know,
but fortunately I've been eating like
a lady, some staying in shape here.
Alright Indochina, everybody. Ah, we're
doing the reeds here and don't cheat.
Oh fuck, fuck the reads.
You know something?
I was reading this
thing about this couple,
that mountain climbs and they were
trying to climb one of the more difficult
ones where you're literally
walking in the jet stream.
It was wind was blowing so bad
they couldn't sleep at night.
So of course one of these fucking morons
gets lifted up in the air by the wind,
slammed down between two rocks.
Her foot gets stuck in between the rocks
and then the wind is blowing so hard,
it twists her body around and
she breaks her fucking leg.
Now the other two fucking jerk offs who
were also completely safe before they
decided of out
of the bucket blue on a nowhere
to put their lives at risk,
right?
With absolutely no respect for anybody
else in the world who gets tortured,
who lives in these horrible fucking war
torn conditions. You know what I mean?
And all they want to do is just
be able to come home and be safe.
These two fucking free morons.
Okay.
Decide that they're going to go up there
with deliberately put their lives at
risk.
So now the other two assholes have to
carry this lady down with their spiral
fracture taking turns while
walking into the jet stream.
And I don't know what I'm supposed to be
doing during this when I'm reading this,
my supposed to be thinking, wow, what
incredible human beings. I don't,
I just think what a couple of fucking
morons because then some poor bastard has
to fly a helicopter up there and try
and meet them and risk his fucking life.
Okay,
Sandra? I, I just, I don't know. I don't
know how people in the coast guard do it.
I don't know how these people in like
helicopters around the fucking world,
their job. What is your job, sir?
What is your job man? We all want is
my job. Oh, I rescue fucking morons.
You don't have, I mean the fire department
has that too. To a certain extent.
You know, somebody sitting
there smoking a cigarette,
eating a pop tart and bed nod off and
he likes his fucking bed on fire, right?
Then they got to go in there and go
get the guys he's hiding in the closet,
you know with the frost and still
around his lips that start in the milk.
They have to go in there.
They got to go get the gun.
I don't have the MD. You want to
talk about fucking hero? How do,
how do they do that?
Yeah.
You have to go risk your
life to save a fucking moron.
Is there making the call? Yeah. Hey, well,
hey my, my wife broke her leg. I got,
Oh yeah, where are you?
Where's your house out? Nah,
we climbed up a mountain.
The fuck did you do that for?
Oh God, I would love to take those calls.
What the fuck did you do that for? Great.
Great. So now let me guess. Now you
want us to go up there and go get you.
You fucking moron.
You know we should leave you up there,
right. You know you deserve that. Right.
Okay.
Do you understand the person flying
up there and the helicopter isn't it,
is expecting it to.
He's becoming a father and another month
and he might not make it because you
fucking idiots left a perfectly good
hotel room and decided to climb up there.
So what? You could talk loudly about it
in a bar with your frostbit and cheeks.
You dumb cunts.
Tell you what,
walking up a thousand feet down the
fucking mountain, I'll check the forecast.
Maybe I'll pick you up in a week.
I guess you got to be cut out for
that job. I don't know. All right. In,
don't cheat. All right. Talk about
how every man looks better in a suit.
You know, every day I'm checking
out guys walking by, you know,
you know, I like it. Nice George Michael
Stubble. I'm not gonna lie to you,
right? But I gotta be telling
me, be honest with you. You know,
nothing makes me want to give my number
to another man, like a man in a suit.
Jesus Christ or they look good.
Um,
Endo Cito is making it easy to get a
perfectly tailored suit and an incredible,
I was just picturing a guy in a
suit doing that stupid Michael, uh,
whatever his fucking name is.
Is it Michael?
Got Ahead faith the faith
faith when I pulled on his too,
I like to wear show anyone like
fucking Joe [inaudible] in good fellas.
Um, end of Chito was making it easy to
get a perfectly tailored suit and an
incredible price.
You can choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics and personalize your suit
just the way you want it.
Who the fuck knows about fabrics?
Whether it then I get to learn about
that. I know. I don't want wool.
I know. I don't want it to be so shiny
that when I walk, you can hear me coming
is I come down the
fucking I'll, um, anyways,
whether it's for work or wedding
or other special occasions,
Indochino has suited up hundreds of
thousands of men and are now the largest
made to measure men's
wear brand in the world.
Here's how it works.
We get a bunch of silk worms,
right? And we booted him right in the ass.
And then I'll come to the fucking silk.
Right. Isn't like silk from
like this spittle of a God damn.
You gotta admit the intelligence
of human beings. You know,
I'm not saying I'm wonderful,
but how the fuck do you do see
some goddamn little worm mining?
It's so God damn business making a little
spider web, whatever the fuck it is.
They do any like,
you know what?
I bet I could take that stuff
and make a shirt out of it.
Yeah.
Um,
visit a shoe.
Visit a showroom or shop online.
indochino.com do these fucking little
silkworms realize that they're working in
a factory.
They give them a little cute lunch pails.
Do they get two weeks vacation a year?
That's what I'm asking you.
I'm sure somebody is doing a
documentary on it. Pick your fabric.
Choose your customizations from lapels
to pleats to jacket linings in more
pleats.
What do we know Molly Ringwald movie?
Those pleaded fucking pants that
that guy from uh, the two guys in,
in fucking Charlie Sheen
in a pizza police sitcom
pleaded suit.
Right.
Okay.
Does that when they put like quotations
around your junk with front of your
pants,
submit your measurements,
place your order and wait for it to
arrive and just a few weeks, you know,
one of the loneliest things you'll
ever do in your life is take your own
measurements.
You know,
Jesus is the cups.
Maybe they're gonna arrest that Mary
and Ed gave for speaking too high.
Now Bill burr listeners can get
indocin knows best deal ever,
ever at $359 for any premium suit when
you enter the code birth during checkout,
that's 50% off the regular price
for a made to measure premium suit.
Uh,
that includes plus the shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code bar for
any premium suit for just $359 and free
shipping and incredible deal for a suit
that will fit you better than anything
off the rack ever could. All
right, frame bridge everybody.
Frame Bridge is the easiest way to kind
of set him free new fever art in photos
without ever leaving your house.
You Fat.
Fuck with their simple
online ordering process.
You can order a fully
customized piece in minutes.
Here's how it works.
You go to Frame bridge.com you upload
your photo from your computer or directly
from your Instagram feed. For the life
of me, I can't get on fucking Instagram.
I signed up years ago. I can not figure
out how to get my fucking password back.
They say they're going to email me. They
never do it. I checked my junk photos,
I check off, uh, and not
photos. My junk files.
I do fucking everything I'm supposed
to do and I can never find it.
Or if you have a physical item,
they'll provide secure prepaid packaging
so you can mail it in for free.
Preview your photo online
in any frame style.
Choose ain't what I want to
do this cause I, there's,
I got a great one with me and my
daughter, you know what I mean? She's,
we're both looking into the mirror,
you know,
and she had a little fat hand is grabbing
a handful of the back of my shirt is
she's laying her head on my chest.
It's the cutest.
It's my favorite picture than
I have of me and her. Oh God,
I gotta get home preview you
photo online in any frame.
She your favorite or get free help
from their talented designers. Uh,
the expert team at frame bridge.
We'll custom custom
frame your item in days,
not weeks or months and deliver your
finished piece directly to your door ready
to hang the best part instead of the
hundreds you pay at a framing store,
their prices start at $39
and all shipping is free.
Plus my listeners will get 15% off their
first order@framebridge.com when they
use my promo code bar frame bridge
even offers a happiness guarantee.
If for some reason you aren't 100%
satisfaction satisfied with the order,
they'll make it right.
Uh,
you should send them a picture
your junk and then call up,
complain about the frame that they use,
telling me that it doesn't,
it offsets your pubes rather
than complementing it. Um,
give your personal experience using frame
bridge. I've never used it. This site,
the ease of order, how your piece turned
out and how easy and affordable it was.
Go to frame bridge.com
and use Promo code bar.
You'll save an additional 15%
off your first order frame,
bridge.com Promo Code Pat.
Thank God somebody fucking solved
the problem of the digital age.
You know what I mean?
I got all these great photos and
I don't even know where they go.
They just go into a fucking hard drive
somewhere. Um, like I was just thinking,
if I get a picture with ric flair tonight
and I replace that photo that I have
on Twitter, I don't know where the
original is. Oh, I know it's somewhere.
I don't know where the fuck it
is. Um, that was cell phones ago.
Thought fee. It's probably in the
ocean right now. You know what?
Ours is probably in Thailand. Some
kid has it, you know what I mean?
And he's going, who the fuck is this
white guy with this even older white guy?
Right?
Thought the everybody thought fee meow.
Everyone had thumb point,
has wished they could have beer,
wine or liquor delivered. Oh God,
he's got to test my sobriety. Well,
someone finally decided to do
something about it. Uh, no. Leggett,
alcoholic who lost
both his legs to the disease.
Next,
please mention all the talking points
both below. Well, I'm going to read it.
You wrote it.
Introducing Southie me out the
alcohol,
the alcohol
deliberately APP saucy delivers
your favorite wine, beer and liquor,
right to your door on demand.
It's Uber for
alcohol.
Now, if you live in La, San Francisco,
Chicago, San Diego, or Sacramento,
I love Sacramento. You know what I mean?
What a major drop off La, San Francisco,
Chicago, San Diego, or
Sacramento. You know,
Sacramento's when you go there,
that's one of those towns you feel like
you're in the Truman show. You know,
or maybe in the first season of the wire,
depending on where you are.
I'm fucking with the Sacramento. But you
know, there's an element of truth. Um,
I'm Hella fucking with you guys up there.
Your thoughts,
the order will arrive at your
door in 30 minutes or less,
ready to drink for the rest of us.
Saucy. We'll deliver beer, wine,
and liquor to your door. In two days
or less. Nationwide. I liked the,
I think the degree of difficulty.
That one. We've got a time.
What boots you're going to need in two
days. Uh, there are no order minimums,
no delivery fees,
no running to the store.
Okay?
Who's kidding? Who? No driving
to the store, shit faced. Um,
if you've got the thought,
the meow APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar on your
phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download the
[inaudible] app and enter Promo Code Bar.
That's the soft,
the APP spelled f a u s e y honey.
And enter your Promo
code birth for $15 off.
Get the saucy Mijo App today and
use your my promo code burpee.
You are. Ah, here's the last one. Oh,
but opal beyond [inaudible] me undies,
no more fucking booze.
Doo,
Doo Doo Doo me undies me undies you live
is going to fucking lose if you booze
too fucking much.
And then you yet can you soft underwear?
I don't know what I'm saying
in this makes no sense.
The vice president's name is Mike parents.
May undies makes undies.
Your Butt will be proud to wear.
Are you sick of your
ass being disappointed?
It's time to make your ass proud again
with a pair of me undies and check this
out. I'm not the only one who loves
me on, you know I love me undies.
It's not even their underwear. I just
like singing even though I'm, you know,
I could barely carry a tune.
Listened to what my long
time listeners and me undies,
enthusiasm George has to say
a note from George and bill,
burr listener and be undies fan.
This is how much you guys so much.
You guys have done a solid with me on
this. You guys actually write them,
telling them how much you liked my songs
to the point they're now sending me
your fucking tweets or Instagram,
whatever the fuck you send it to them
and now this is part of the copy I guess.
Anyways,
this is from George and who allegedly
exists and wrote this and this is not from
some advertising company.
I decided to try me on these because I
love bill burrs. Me On these jingles.
I smile every time he sings
it. A man wrote that. Now,
if this was a lady,
I believe that a lady would be emotionally
open enough to say that I smile every
time he sings it. I think
this has been edited. Um,
although it's so easy to
skip ads in a podcast,
I always capital's listened to bill's
reads and I'm so glad me undies has stuck
with them.
It's probably been two years since I
first bought a pair of me undies and now I
have a monthly subscription
because they are that comfortable.
Doesn't this Raul read is
phony before me undies.
I used to buy the three pack of underwear
at the retail stores until I realized
that I wanted to treat my junk to
something more comfortable and that starts
with a great pair of BMDS,
cradling my family jewels.
This is so fucking written
by their advertising teams.
I know you guys are writing them in.
I know you're writing these
guys telling you like,
I mean that there's no fucking
way you write it that eloquently.
This was totally edited. I'm
calling bullshit. But anyways,
to get 20% off the best, softest
underwear and socks you'll ever own,
free shipping and 100% satisfaction
guarantee. You know, we have to go.
You have to go to me
undies.com/ [inaudible] that's
me on [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] all right,
what are we up to? Oh,
that's 35 minutes. Okay, well I got,
I got to work in my little workout.
I'm going to go put,
put on my pink legwarmers you know,
and do a couple of buck blasters.
All I do now is I just get on
the elliptical. That's all I do.
And I put on my fucking, uh, you guys
want to hear about why my cardio?
This is my cardio. I like to listen
to mindless music when I'm on,
you know,
I finally have given into gym music.
Like I used to walk around the gym and
I'd be like, Ugh, why are they playing?
Pour some sugar on me? It's like, you
know, cause it's actually, you know,
I go through different periods.
Sometimes I didn't want to listen
to a fucking absolutely genius,
um, album or something like that.
Or I just don't even want to think.
And lately I don't want to fucking
think and I know what it is,
is because I'm missing my family.
That's what it is that I mentioned
that 5,000 fucking times.
So right now I just want to go into
like, you know, it's like, why, you know,
I like washing dishes. It's fucking
mindless, you know what I mean?
Uh, but the water in the tank
with the top and I Bunkage
until it's clean and it's just gives you
something to do, something to focus on.
Like why can't I get that fucking brand
flake that looks like now it's been
sandblasted under this bowl here. Why
can't I get that off clock? Shocking.
You know, you get a little anger
out. Um, here, here is my, um,
my mindless music.
I listened to fail it steel feel
it still from Portugal, the man
[inaudible] [inaudible] and
my comment at a left field,
Oh god, he got it. Got that Gagaku
that gets me,
it gets me through the first five minutes.
And then I listened to mark
Ronson, uptown funk. Oh,
this is the same song, the same
song they write every summer, right?
Boop, boop. I listen to that
shit. Right? Slightly embarrassed.
But I listened to it and then I
listened to the honey drippers rocket at
midnight.
And uh,
then I just have a bunch of Tom Petty,
and this isn't mindless music,
but I'm kind of stopping listening
to that. I kind of switch off.
Then I've listened to three mindless
songs in a row and I love Tom Petty,
but he just died. So it makes
me sad. So I just saw primus.
So after those three mindless
songs, I then go into, oh,
I go into awesome music
music that I really like.
I'll listen to Primus or Mars Volta,
my new favorite band,
fucking dope found out about them fucking
15 years after they were together.
So stupid. Um, so anyways, and that's
when I have to go do so everybody,
you guys want to share with me your a
little cardio fucking list. I need you.
I need,
I need another three fucking songs as
mindless as those first three that I just
sent to you.
This silly to happy.
And next thing you know, I looked
down and all I had, you know,
I only do like a half hour,
you know what I mean?
I only do a half hour because these needs
have to last me a lifetime. All right,
I'm with this bullshit.
Um,
there's going to be a little music here
and you're probably not going to know
what the music is and I'm not going to
know what it is either because Andrew
Feminists, uh, you know, he goes deep,
he goes deep into the music world.
So if you have any questions,
just ask what song it is on our
Twitter app at the MM podcast.
All right. And ask Andrew and they very
polite, respectful way, what the song is.
I'm sure he'll get back to you. All
right. And uh, then we'll play after that.
There'll be another half hour, this
podcast, a classic half hour, um, of,
of classic clips from a Thursday
afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast that, um, I
don't know, maybe from early this year,
maybe from three years ago.
I have no idea.
You might even listen to me talking about
how much fun I had boobs in the night
before, you know, uh,
that's it. All right.
Have a great weekend and
I'll talk to you on Monday.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
anyways,
I get them into the biggest,
dumbest fucking fight last
night with my girl, right?
We had this great day, you
know, everything's going great.
So I stay in, I take a night off from
comedy and I say, Hey, why don't we watch,
why don't we watch a movie?
You know what I mean?
Cap Off this wonderful fucking
day. Everything's going
great. What could go wrong?
This is like the beginning of a horror
movie where they just show like the
perfect family and everything's great
and people are wearing like white linen,
you know?
And then all of a sudden they just
start showing the camera and the bushes,
like a POV of like Mike Myers.
This is basically what happened.
So 60 minutes comes on,
right?
Who doesn't want to watch that show
and pretend they're smart, you know,
I like it some more that Morley
safer comes on and you know,
we smells like an old person. Some old
people don't smell like old people,
but he looks like he smells
like an old person, you know,
smells of cigars, ash trays,
you know, couple of wars,
maybe a date rape.
Um,
so he's interviewing Meryl Streep,
alright,
the great Meryl Streep,
and they're going through all oral,
oral frigging life and all the movies
and all the different characters that
she's played. Oh, first
of all, they start,
they start the report off with
Morley safer just sitting there,
right. Smelling a fucking Ben
Gay in whiskey. Right. And uh,
he says,
how you,
how over in England, you
know, they, you know, I dunno,
they make their, their actors, they,
they award them by calling
them lords and they night them.
But over here in America,
all we do is just give him the
shiny statue and it's just like,
starts off right off the bat for some
reason, just shitting on America.
I don't know why.
Like an Oscar is somehow beneath
sir, uh, Anthony Michael Hall. I mean,
or, or Lord, what it Lord of what,
what are what.
At least you can fucking hold our statue,
your lord of what kingdom,
that phony horseshit that you have with
Prince Charles in the popper or whatever
the fuck is going on over there.
You know,
look up the Rothschilds night you over
there, then that fucking means something.
Then you can come become
part of their yacht convoys.
They go around the world figuring out
how to take over another currency, right?
Then you're in with them. Okay. But if
you're, if you're fucking, you know,
Lord of this and your, your wing man
is the Duke of Elton John. I mean,
that's the whole thing is fucking
stupid, right? So right off the bat,
it's already bugging me. But I know Nia
hates when I talk to the TV rights. So I,
you know,
I keep my big fucking Yap shut and
they started talking about Meryl Streep
[inaudible] gone through the whole thing
and then I'm the old guy there smelling
of uh, you know, prescription
meds goes, uh, you know,
whenever they talk about the roles
you play, they always say, you know,
you play independent minded women,
very strong women. And Merrill goes,
I know that's, yeah, that's what
they say. You know, when a guy,
they never say to a guy, oh, you're
playing a strong willed character,
Yadda Yadda Yadda. I let that go,
whatever, no Biggie, I'll take that.
It's probably true. The fuck do I
know I'm not a whole woman. Right.
But then they show her after she played
Margaret Thatcher and she's given a
speech to a bunch of women's young girls.
She's trying to inspire them and she,
she takes a quote from Margaret Thatcher
and it was something along the lines of,
if you want a bunch of
people to talk around,
talk is staying around talking
about doing something. You know,
something, I go to Iga,
you got to talk to men,
but if you want it to actually get done,
you gotta get a woman and then all the
chicks go, whoo, like flipping out. Right?
So I laughed and I'm like,
Yay. Reverse sexism, right?
Just seeing, you know, my,
my whole fucking theory how
everybody is just a piece of shit.
You just don't have the power to act
out what the fuck you want to do because
that, that right there, if
you flip that around as a guy,
if you're running for president,
it's fucking over. He can't be like,
let me tell you know,
tell you what after I get you
jobs and after I fix this economy,
okay. And I'm the man to do it
because I'll tell you right now,
if you're looking for someone to
stand around and talk about doing,
you get a woman, you want to
get done, you gotta get 'em man,
here are my nuts right here on the podium.
Volt from me.
November 4th go fuck
yourself. Right? You did that.
Your presidential campaigns over.
She does it. It's fucking adorable.
And it's just as fucking ignorant.
You know what I mean?
What a fuck do you get off saying
that we stand around and do nothing,
Meryl Streep or quoting Margaret
and you too, Margaret Thatcher.
Let me taste you bitches something. All
right, we faked a fucking lunar landing.
Okay? You think that's just talking.
Anybody can land on the fucking moon.
That's easy.
But to pretend you did it all right and
get everybody to shut the fuck up about
it. That, that, that, that right
there, that takes skill. So whatever.
So I make that little comment and um,
did I just go with it that, that, that,
that are certainly fucking porky pig.
So,
so I make that comment and like,
you know,
I've been with Nia long enough that I
can tell by the side of her face when
she's just thinking about like,
what if I just grabbed everything I
really cared about and walked out of this
house right now?
She got like that fucking mad at me,
you know? And I'm like, she's just like,
right after the story was over, she just
shut the fucking thing off. And, uh,
I only happen to excel. I'm walking
to seven 11 and get some ice cream.
I've not even, what happened
was all going great. You know,
I might be asshole there.
What am I?
Am I supposed to just fucking sit there
with my mouth hanging open with drool
coming out when I watch TV?
If somebody says something Douchey,
I'm not supposed to say it.
Yeah. Whatever, whatever.
So I just finally just said, you know
what? Fuck this. I take the dog out.
I go around the block. What do I do?
I'm calling my guy friends, right?
They're all backing me up. I'm not
saying who I called, I don't name names.
All right.
And they're all laughing their ass
off and they get 100% agree with me,
which is all I'm looking
for at this point.
I just want people to say that I'm right.
I don't want to learn
anything from this experience.
Just tell me I was right so I
can be an ignorant ass again.
I don't know. Why don't you guys weigh
in on that? Am I a Dick for saying that?
Should I just let that one go? You
know? Oh, you know what she said?
That fucking drove me up the
wall. She goes, why are you,
she didn't say intimidated.
She used one of those words.
Why are you threatened by what she said?
It's like I'm not threatened.
I, yeah, Jesus Christ. Then
I take the bait, you know,
it just sends me right all day, like
threatened about what? Oh my God.
This person that I don't know who has
never called me, nor will ever call me,
who has no effect on my life.
How do you get threatened by that?
I'm just calling it for the bullshit.
That is, cause you know what?
This is what fucking drives me nuts.
I can't stand when somebody tells me
that this shit sandwich tastes worse than
my shit sandwich. Okay, go fuck yourself.
At what point am I supposed
to have empathy as I'm
sitting here eating the shit
sandwich and you're telling me how
much worse yours yours is. You know,
at the end of the fucking day, you know
what I mean? Sure. Mine might be on a,
you know,
a better slice of bread,
which I guess would make it
taste a little bit better,
but at the end of the fucking day,
right? The end of the fucking day.
All right, I'm going to end up
in a FEMA camp with you. Okay?
You think when the next fucking psycho
comes along, I'm going to make the cut.
What the fuck do I put? What do I
bring to the world? Huh? Exactly.
And be standing right next to you.
So go fuck yourself and you just
fucking woman. Every time she sneezes,
they give her another goddamn award. She
still pitching, still fucking bitching.
You know it's, I remember when I
did this Oscar nominated part out.
Go Fuck yourself with your wigs.
Don't think just, you know,
that's what fucking pisses me
off when I watched this shit.
If you really want to know my
perspective is from where I come from,
I can't bitch about shit cause
everyone's like, oh go fuck yourself.
You hit the lottery. Right. But I
gotta sit here and listen to you bitch.
Even if you fucking killing it,
even if you're killing it, you know,
Yale School of drama and
he's still doing the ball.
Go Fuck yourself with your goddamn yachts.
Alright,
there you go. That, that felt
good. It's probably ignorant.
[inaudible]
dental assistant billion.
I recently,
I recently watched a talk show appearance.
You posted on your Twitter you
mentioned. Yeah, I did the, uh,
the Willie Hunter show.
MMM.
And I think that that's what I posted
when that fucking twice that I'd like to
choke to death with a garden hose
sent me that tweet. Um, yeah,
it was on the Willie Hunter show.
And he said,
you mentioned you were a dental
assistant, um, for your father.
Did you ever consider becoming a dentist?
Did you ever,
did your father ever have ambitions for
you to become anything in particular?
Um, no. My Dad, my parents
were great. Like they,
they wanted you to base it.
They didn't force anything on you.
It was like whatever you wanted to do.
MMM.
They supported it 100%.
And I remember being working with my
dad in the dental office when I told him
that I was going to become a comedian.
We were in like the break room and I
remember I was sitting there like going
like,
how is guy going to take this when he
has such a classic like stable job here?
You know that I'm going to tell
him that I'm going to fucking
basically make a living,
try to make a living doing exactly what
he's been yelling at me for for the last
fucking 20 years of my life,
which was fucking off and acting like an
idiot and screwing around all the shit
that you know,
when he would give me Christ
check up box in a town clown,
what do you be giving me?
Shit.
Which I totally deserved because if you
ever saw the grades I got in school,
I mean they, they, they are, they
are horrific, fucking horrific.
The high water mark for me was
like a c minus or a c like I was,
it was brutal.
I want you to head to go to summer
school every fucking year of high school
except my sophomore year
because my math teacher hooked me up
in my senior year. I should've gone.
I just didn't give a fuck. I was like,
what's the point? You know what I mean?
That's like, you got the ball
with 10 seconds left in you.
What are you going to do? You just
fucking, you know, you're down by 30 dad.
Just throw up a half court shot. Did it go
in? Who gives a fuck? It doesn't matter.
You know? Um, so no,
I mean for half a second. You know what
you know, and I did like, I like the, uh,
I like the pouring up
models when I was in a,
when I was in the dental office, that
was my favorite thing. I was in the back.
I was isolated.
I wasn't around anybody and it tapped
into that little kid thing of playing in
mud
and he used to pour up the models and
they had this vibrating thing and you had
to tap on it to make sure you
have got all the bubbles out.
And I prided myself on not
being able, you know, I've,
I've having it without no having
no bubbles. If you got bubbles,
if there was bubbles on the bottom,
basically,
you know when they stick that pink shit
in your mouth, they got to take a, uh,
an impression of your teeth.
Then somebody's got to take that out of
your mouth going in the back room and
then you got it.
You got to mix this powder with water up
in the little green rubber bowls. Jesus,
this is all coming back to me.
And then you poured it into the
fucking impression you took.
And then there was this,
this thing that sounded exactly like
your cell phone vibrating on a table and
you just, you just tapped it on that
to get all the air bubbles out of it.
And if you didn't do it enough after one
of the things set and you took it out,
um,
if the bubbles were at the bottom,
that's where the teeth were
the most crucial thing,
the exact fucking thing that trying to
get a gauge on so they can, you know,
whatever the hell they were trying to
do, make a bridge or something. Um,
the whole thing would be fucked.
And then you couldn't go and just rapport
the model into that same mold because
somehow like it had shrunk up
little bit and it wouldn't be
accurate.
And my dad used to flip out.
He would, he would take them
off, he'd be like, Christ,
there's air bubbles and this,
you know, and it was beyond your boss
yelling at you. It was also my dad's.
So I already had,
you know,
I was going through my fucking teenage
and early twenties when you're rebelling
the most against your fire.
Already had the live with the guy.
And then I was working with the most
fucking hilarious and he used to give me
shit. Bye. You know, like I was his kid.
Okay.
But we,
we really have,
we actually talked about how we had to
tone that shit down because it didn't
come off as professional in front
of patients or whatever. But uh,
but that was a part I thought if I ever
got into dentistry that I would, I would,
I would work in the lab.
I liked that part of it, like, um,
and not just pouring up
the models like the actual,
I know there was a precision to it
that I liked. I didn't like to fight.
I didn't like the,
uh,
the front line shit going in the mouth
with all that crap and looking at
people's fucking horrific teeth,
just horrible fucking teeth.
All my jokes were about that
shit when I first started.
I told you guys that story,
right?
I used to work totally clean
when I first started stand up.
Um, and not because I want
it to be this comedy purist.
I just was afraid of offending
somebody in the crowd, getting heckled,
not having a comeback,
losing my place in my act and
then bombing horrifically. Yeah.
And, and just having my career
and total fear catastrophizing,
like way of looking at it.
And um,
yeah. Oh Jesus Christ, that really
just fucking brought me back to,
I was standing on stage at sticks,
stitches.
Fucking somebody heckled me
was that the vault in Boston,
somebody had called me and I completely
lost my fucking train of thought and I
had nothing and I didn't. And it took
me like basically three seconds to, to,
to re to remember what the fuck
I was talking about. And um,
it was the longest 30 seconds of my life
and I didn't know enough to just say to
the crowd like, what the fuck was I
talking about? Cause they'll tell you,
they'll remember. They're not
nervous, they're listening. They,
they're not having like this outer
body experience. Um, but anyways,
I remember people would come into the
dental office in their teeth would just be
just,
yeah,
just what an absolute fucking mess.
And they can tell you right
now, I hate coming to the
dentist. And it's like, yeah,
dude, I can smell it.
You don't have to smile.
I can tell you don't
like coming to a dentist.
You only like fucking brushing your teeth.
Well just one guy said this,
one of the first jokes I did too.
Oh that's right.
So I will work totally fucking clean.
And then my last at my, and you just,
you know when I looked
like a young Ron Howard,
I look like Richie Cunningham and I was
totally clean and I was clever and I had
these perfect talk show monologue jokes
and everyone was going like, oh dude,
you're going to do the
tonight or this is going
to be perfect for and blah blah blah blah
blah. And then the last joke in my act,
I quoted this patient who kept having
to get fillings and root canals and he,
and he said, doc, you know, I
don't understand what's going on.
I mean I brushed my
teeth almost every day.
And then my,
my snappy comeback to that,
that I thought of that later became the
last joke on my act. I said, really deal.
Wipe your ass almost every
time you take a shit.
And that's what I would close
with after working totally clean.
I would say that disgusting lie.
Do you wipe your ass almost
every time you take a shit?
Having everybody in the
crowd after looking at this
fucking Norman Rockwell come
to life fucking character
wholesome is hell right.
Yeah.
And I really was back then as opposed
to the piece of shit that I am now after
20 years on the road that I became.
Um,
and I literally, they had to conjure
up pictures of somebody skipping,
wiping their ass and just that whole,
and they would just literally recoil.
Then I would just be like,
you know,
thanks a lot. Can I get everybody?
You would great. And um,
yeah,
I had another horrible one that I did,
um,
where I actually brought a prop on
stage and if you'd like to see that,
I tell the story on the Willie Hunter
show and a willys and up and coming comic
at the comedy store. I've, and
he's the go through the Hula Hoop,
took the hula hoop from that girl in,
fucking threw it into the the street.
I tell that story too. If you want
to see that shit, check out his show.
[inaudible] Hey, what's going on? It's
built, Bro. This is the Monday morning
podcasts for Monday, October 26th, 2009.
Holy Shit. Halloween's coming up. I
haven't even bought a pumpkin yet.
What the fuck is that all about?
Um,
hey, how come there's not pumpkin's the
whole time of the year? All those things.
Seasonal, you know, like tomatoes.
Evidently tomatoes are seasonal.
We just don't realize that,
which is why they taste like shit 90%
of the year or according to Jimmy Dore,
they pick them before they're even
ripe and they just paint them red.
Um, is that true? I mean,
how long would that take to sit there
with that little fucking Crayola?
It wouldn't, they taste like wax.
What's the deal with Pumpkins?
You can get Pumpkin Pie, the
whole euro, but you never see you.
Um, I've gone out of my fucking my
people, my voice is killing me. Um,
I have something to do
here in fucking 40 minutes.
So this is gonna be a quick podcast.
And this time actually mean it because
it's going to cost me money if I don't
get off the phone here in 40
minutes. Uh, uh, where to start.
Why don't we just start with
what the hell's bugging me? Um,
I almost got into a
fistfight yesterday and, uh,
I realized that I'm at the awful age of,
it's basically any time there's
going to be a fist fight,
I have these two options.
A I lose and get the
shit kicked out of me,
which really, you know, there's no end
to, that shit kicked out of you. Could be,
I got a black eye, I
lost a twofer, you know,
or it could be I'm in a coma and you know,
the left side of my body doesn't
work anymore. You know what I mean?
You never know because you never
know who you fucker went. Right.
So that's option a and option B is I win
and then I get the shit sued out of me.
Okay. I see. I'm so fucking
still pissed about this. I'm,
I have to give you the abbreviated
version of this because it's,
it's been eating me up inside.
Um,
I was waiting for my girlfriend
to come out of this diner,
this one of these places. There's only
one way in and one way out. All right,
so there's a parking lot,
parking spot way down,
which is actually closer to the fucking
diner in this Douche bag is sitting
there cause he sees my reverse lights on.
So I'm way of an Adam to tell him to
go by me so I can just back out of the
fucking light. And he's just sitting
there sitting there. He wouldn't do it.
It's a fire, you know, pull out real
fast. It's like a gravel parking lot,
slam on the brakes, slide backwards and
then fly forward. Slam on the brakes.
So he pulls in,
obviously knows I'm pissed and I back
up and I put the window down. I'm like,
dude, there's a fucking spot right up
there. And then he immediately goes, oh,
you're so tough with your hybrid. And
he really caught me off guard, man.
He got me with a great money.
Went with the hybrid.
My Dick is bigger than yours because I'm,
he's driving a fucking lime green
four door sedan that he looked like he
borrowed from his fucking ant, right? Oh,
this guy, you just this, this fucking,
you know what this guy looked like?
Remember those coming of age movies in
the 80s where there was the good looking
chick, uh, that the nerd wanted and
she was dating this impossible asshole.
Like that blonde hair Douche from our
back to school who gets all intimidated in
the end and fix a leg injury after fucking
a 90 year old Rodney Dangerfield does
a triple, triple Lindy. That's
what this kid look like. All right?
And he's gone fucking Blah, blah,
blah. And I'm like, Hey, yeah,
we'd get fucking tight shirt and your big
nose. Go Fuck Yourself. And he's like a,
and then he goes, yeah, I go back
to Jersey. You piece of shit.
That's what he said to me. Right?
And I wanted to go like, dude,
I'm not from New Jersey, but my girl
jumped in and said something fucking,
you know, that a civilian would
say rather than a comedian.
So I started losing the
argument a little bit.
So then he turns around and then I was
just like, where you going? Where you go?
And you know,
like,
like I was actually going to fight
him because I was so fucking mad. I
okay.
But I in the back of my head, the whole
fucking time, I'm thinking like, dude,
what are you going to do? What? What you,
what are you going to do to this guy?
When was the last time you had a fight?
You're fucking 41 you're a year older than
Brett. Farve what are you going to do?
It's not even on level ground.
It's in a gravel fucking parking lot.
You know what I mean? I knew
I could've, I, I swear to God,
I know I could have fucking
killed this guy, but I, well,
I can't do it. [inaudible] I already,
you know what would've happened?
I would've fucking started fighting him.
Even if I started winning,
his girlfriend would've jumped on my back.
And then if you do any sort of,
get off my back with the woman,
I'm going to jail.
You know? I just, it was
this fucking stalemate.
There was nothing I could fucking do.
And then I'm driving home and all I'm
thinking about is how much I want to
fucking kill this guy.
And it got to the point,
I literally dropped my girl off and I
drove back to the diner and his fucking
car were still there.
And I'm circling the diner in a hybrid
waiting for this guy to come out thinking
about what I'm gonna do to him and
then also reminding myself that I have
not had a fight in about 20 fucking years.
Okay.
And then also reminded myself legally
the ramifications for leaving and then
fucking coming back.
I am in no danger whatsoever and I am
going to get the living shit sued out of
me.
So fortunately a friend of mine happened
to call up and I started telling her
the story and she was laughing her ass
off and she told the story of solves some
girl didn't hold the door,
you know,
it's one of those really heavy doors and
sorta in its sort of slam back in her
face. And she said, thank you.
You know, sarcastically tour,
and then the girl goes a one,
I don't have to hold the door for you.
Go Fuck Yourself.
And how she just wanted to
sticker timberland through
the back of this fucking
chicks.
Yeah,
back. I guess. Look at me. I'm so fucking
mad. I can't even say simple anatomy,
so I just, I dunno.
I was able to just kind of talk myself
out of it and the real thing was I didn't
want to go back and fight the guy. I
really didn't, you know what I mean?
I really didn't. I did, but I didn't.
There was just no when it wasn't going to
do, you know, I got meetings this week,
I'm going to show up with a loose
tooth and a fucking, you know,
nobody bleeds like a red head.
You know what I mean?
I'm going to look like fucking
ric flair walking in there.
There was nothing I could do.
I had to sit there and I think I
actually lost the back and forth.
Verbal thank you know, I'm so
fucking shot from being on the road.
I just got off a flight. I wanted to go
straight home. I girls like I'm hungry,
let's get Sunday,
you know,
and I made a mental note to be extra
nice to my girl just because I've been an
asshole lately,
you know,
which is probably why I got into
the argument to begin with. But
it's, it was, it,
I literally that desert desert
fucking reservoir or a lake,
whatever the fuck you call it, near
where I live. This is how mad I was
after my friend talked me out of not
doing what I didn't even want to do to
begin with. Right. Not to mention the,
you already had another guy with him.
I would've lost. I would've
fucking lost. Right. So, um,
I had to go drive to the lake,
park my car and walk around the lake
in the first 90% of the walk around it.
I was fantasizing about all the different
ways that I was going to murder this
guy.
I had one where I was body slamming
him onto his own fucking car,
screaming some shit about hybrids.
I completely like, I haven't been
that mad in so fucking long. And, uh,
it wasn't until the last 10%, you know,
I was kind of going like, you know,
you really took this walk to
try to forget about this shit,
so what is wrong with you?
You need to calm down.
So I started to fucking calm down and uh,
then I saw my car again and reminded me
I was driving a hybrid in a fucking piss
me off again, be told it's been one
thing if the guy was driving a corvette,
you should have seen this car.
It wasn't lime green.
It was actually kind of a nice screen.
Okay.
If I can actually extend an olive
branch to this fucking cunt.
But I mean it was, it was a
four door sedan. You know,
there was no excuse at his age,
your name,
he's like in his twenties there was no
fucking excuse for him to be driving that
car or certainly talking shit.
Right.
And also I love that whole go back to
Jersey you piece of shit and like how he's
the typical La Guy, you
know, judging you, you know,
you are what you drive out here.
Cause I'm in a hybrid,
therefore I don't know how to fight
in what you hit. You know my car,
my car runs a home for an odd guess.
Fucking bring Bruce Lee odd,
you know, he, what is he going
to Rick Shaw, you know, so,
so the last 10% I started talking myself
down and just so happened there was an
open house out here and there happens to
be a zillion houses available out here
because the state is bankrupt and we
live in a city without a water supply and
they still want $1 million for a house
that is about the size of a decent one
bedroom apartment. So a ants,
hence there's a lot of open houses.
So I actually said,
I actually went into the open house and
looked at it and was thinking the entire
time that if I had gotten out of
the car and thrown the first punch,
even if I won the fight,
whatever downpayment,
I woulda had to actually
get a fucking house,
which is something I'd like to do at some
point in my life that would have been
out the fucking window.
And as much as it calmed me down today,
it still hasn't made me feel any better.
And, uh, this, this,
this should be like some
sort of gentleman's agreement
of I'm not going to sue
you in. My friends aren't going to
jump in, maybe even go down to the gym.
You just put the gloves on so
he can just get it out of you.
Because I got to admit it's still
fucking in me. And Ah, I've been,
ah, the, ah, this is how much of a
contents made me and I'm trying to get,
I'm trying to get rid of this, this,
this little ball of hate that is in me.
When I was, I looked at the
one house, right? And I've,
and I felt better and I'm like, I still
need to look at another house because,
you know, I'm gonna, I'm
still in a bad mood. And, um,
I was driving up the street
as I'm driving up the street.
This white lady is like waving her
hands, like telling me to stop. She,
she's gives no uniform, no
uniform on or nothing. So I kinda,
you know,
I'm,
I'm deliberately driving pastor a little
bit before I slowed down cause I'm a
fucking control freak and I like
people telling me what to do.
So she comes up to my window
and I go, what? And she's like,
I'm a tree fell on the road around the
corner. I just didn't want you to hit it.
And I was just like, oh my God, I am
the biggest asshole ever. I really am.
You don't if I'm really going
to be honest with myself,
the whole fucking reason I had that
fight with that guy is because I'm in a
grumpy mood because the last seven out of
last eight weeks I've been on the road.
All right there. All right. I
admit my fucking part of it.
Oh do you could have seen the
weather go is just standing there.
They're fucking shark fin of a noses.
Hibbs coming out from
those awful sunglasses.
That's going to hurt me for
another couple of days. But, um,
thank God I am a little bit older
and I actually know how my brain,
I'll tell you, that's what I've been
older is, is knowing how your brain works.
Okay?
Because the moment is gone.
So now I'm gonna do is just walk
around hate in this fucking guy.
So what I have to do is every
time I think that I just,
I just fucking think of something else.
Um,
and I've been able to do it in my
apartment, but when I get in my car,
it's like a Vietnam fucking flashback.
So I'm just going to give myself
a week to get over it. And, uh,
and that's it. All right, so there's a
story for you that took a nice 12 minutes.
My fucking voice is killing me.
You know,
I actually bought a book on how to
fucking use your voice properly on stage.
I should really read it.
I do drink that throat coat.
Fucking a tea with honey.
Now that's how old I am.
Um,
what I really should be doing is giving
my voice arrest and shutting the fuck up
rather than yelling about some dude who
doesn't even matter in my fucking life.
Ah. All right, let's
get on with the podcast.
So this is the Monday morning podcast.
Everybody, if you're new to this,
you're probably in some sort of a,
I don't know what you would,
what mindset you would be in this
old ceiling fans dry out my throat.
That's what's going on.
Um,
is this something really
intimidating about a ceiling fan?
You ever not think that it's just going
to come flying off the fucking ceiling
and decapitate you? It's
unreal how it just stays. There
are pumpkin seasonal, I didn't even get
back to that. I gotta get, I, you know,
you know what happened last year is I
carved up a couple of them but I carved
them up too early and uh,
they started to dry out and the
thing that I, I had carved in there,
this scary looking face and had
carved like a whole silhouette in the,
in the background, you know what I mean?
It's like a carved out, like a big circle,
three quarters of the way.
And then on the bottom I carved the
head into the bottom part of the circle.
So then the candle was behind it and
fucking lift this thing up and it was
awesome. But the weight
of the, uh, the face,
considering it wasn't connected
to any other part of the Pumpkin,
it started to fall into the
hole. Is it dehydrated? And uh,
it really wasn't scary come Halloween.
It was just kind of sad.
It looked like a defeated demon. Like
he's looking up in the air like, God,
what do I have to do to scare people?
Um,
yeah. So anyways, I just came back
from the DC Improv, everybody and uh,
I want to thank everybody in Washington
DC and the surrounding area of Baltimore,
Richmond, Richmond, Virginia, Georgetown,
whatever the hell you
came from West Virginia.
I just want to thank all
you guys for coming out.
That was the greatest turnout I have
ever had to any stand up a weekend I've
ever had.
I actually had to add a show people.
I did a second show on a
Thursday night and it's sold out.
I did six sold out shows
and, uh, three days.
And, um, had the time of my life
ate at this restaurant.
Posh,
got hooked up there by chef Chris is
fucking dude brought us out all his food.
Want to thank him. Oh, it
was a great time, dude.
You know what else I did? I actually,
we got a football to long fucking story.
This is the Peter Pan Lifestyle.
I'm living it,
which really gives me no excuse to get
mad at some guy in a green four door
sedan in the parking lot
of a goddamn diner. Right.
I played football on a Friday
afternoon around two in the afternoon.
Like I was still in like the fifth
grade, you know, that she's fifth grade,
be more around four and it'd be blowing
off my homework or whatever, you know,
and uh, ended up spraining my
finger cause uh, Paul Versey,
the comedian who opened up for me.
It was, we were so fucking hilarious.
Like typical, you know, he's
still a younger guy, but you know,
I'm 41 so I'm stretching and
doing all this shit and uh,
we're sitting there lying to ourselves,
but we could still play.
That was a great pair, dude. You hit me
right in stride. Get me right in stride.
He's getting all excited that he's
hitting a 41 year old and stride,
like the defensive back couldn't catch up
in fucking run the thing back for
six the other way. But uh, Nah man,
I was psyched.
I was really impressed with how fast I
can still run and I'm gonna tell you why.
It's because I've kept myself in shape
and I stretch on a regular basis for all
you guys out there. As you get older, you
have a look at older guys and you like,
you just look at him and you get to an
age at some point where you can't fucking
run anymore and it blows your
mind when you're young. Like,
why can't you run anymore?
You just send them that brain signal
to your legs to run and is to promise
because it hurts. I mean, look,
this, this part of it is, yeah,
you walked on your legs, your
feet, and you use your body,
the wear and tear 40 years.
But I swear to God,
it seems like 80% of it is not stretching.
If you don't stretch,
you get atrophy and your muscles shrivel
up. And that's when you literally,
somebody throws you a ball and it's a
little out of your reach and you go to
reach for it and all of a sudden you
fucking your kidneys up by where your
fucking shoulder blade is.
It's a kidney attached
attendance and a fucking knows.
You know what I'm trying to say? I went
from muscles and tendons to Oregon's, um,
I'm telling you, uh, I,
I have this power yoga tape that
I've been doing forever and forever.
My friends had been teasing me do,
that's gay. What are you doing yoga for?
What are you trying to suck
your own Dick? Eh, right.
All those fucks continue to eat and they
didn't stretch and I was never fast.
I could always catch,
he always had great hand eye coordination.
I could fucking catch anything.
I don't give a shit what it is.
My thing is that there's just going to
be somebody in front of me because I was
never fast. So this is hilarious.
I was never fast. Okay.
But I kept myself in shape.
And about seven or eight years ago
when I was in my early thirties,
I was playing pickup football and we've
been playing for about 20 minutes.
And for the first time in
my life, somebody on the
opposing team actually said,
they said, hey, watch out
for Berger. He's fast.
And I almost burst out laughing because
I was thinking of what a statement,
what that was to the horrific shape that
they were in because I was slow when I
should have been fast.
I ran like a 30 year old when I was 17.
So when I'm 33, I got to be
running like I'm 45. Um, you know.
So anyways, we had a great
time and uh, I got to tell you,
you know what I realized when I
was throwing that football around,
and this is one of the sad things
about being an adult and getting
responsibility and not being able to
have a fight because you could get sued,
is does a lot of other fun things
that you just stopped doing.
Like throwing a football dean,
how much I love football and how
much I loved it when I was a kid.
And do you know how long it's
been such I threw a football,
I can't remember the last,
I think the last time I threw a football
was that day I was talking about when
they said get berries fast,
which was like 33. Like,
I honestly in the last eight years can
not remember ever throwing a football.
Do you know,
fucking tragic that is,
we will out there running post
patterns. It's fucking, you know,
cutting across the middle.
I was having the time of my
life until I sprained my finger.
But even then it was all right.
Just say it looks like when a Elton
John's fingers ever see an Elton John
Concert and he plays with those little
fat little sausage fingers he has.
He always talks about it.
He doesn't have piano playing fingers
cause he can't really reach that far.
But he's still the shit cause he's
so gifted. That's what I have.
I have one Elton John Index
finger or Mario Batali.
Anybody Watch the food
network and you watch when he,
after he does the well
method making the pasta,
which is something I
really want to fucking try,
always want to try and
make my own homemade pasta.
I really got into cooking for a minute.
I used to watch that show Molto Mario
everyday because he seemed like the real
deal, you know? Not only
did he understand that dish,
he had been to the country where it
bends it. You know, he'd been to Italy,
hung around with the Italians and they
taught them how to fucking make this
stuff after they gave them a ton of
shit for not knowing what he was doing.
He can explain the part of Italy that it
came from. It's just a tremendous show.
And I liked that he
does in his own kitchen.
He just has like a couple of
friends over, you know? And uh,
I don't know,
I just looked at it and like a comedy
kind of way where he just seemed like a
comedian who's really a comedian.
Like they don't need props.
They don't need a catch phrase. He's just
standing there doing his shit. Right.
As opposed to other shows where you got,
you know, like, uh, I was going say,
Emilio Estevez what the fuck's
that guy's Amro Lugosi you know,
this is not about just how much
I got into the food network.
I could actually tell how much happier
Emeril Lagasse was when he was doing
essence of Emeril as opposed to being
in front of the crowd. You know,
who doesn't like working in front of a,
of a live audience,
but you could see the sadness in his
face when the crowd just sits there and
then he has to do all that extra shit.
All of a sudden you got to
turn it into like, you know,
I've got some butter and everybody's like
start screaming where I essence Amroy
you can just sit down and cook the dish
and not have to sit there throwing flour
over his shoulder and sugar
into the eyes of his drummer.
He's got a fucking drummer on a
goddamn cooking show. Um, so anyways,
that's what I'm saying. Like
look, if you love football,
you haven't played in a while.
Stretch out and throw the ball around.
I'm telling you, you got to do it. Do it
before you fucking team plays on Sunday.
That's one of those silent silent
competitions I have with with other guys.
You know,
you're going to a sports bar and you
just look at the horror that is a sports
bar, a complete artist shape, fat fucks,
the bloated alcohol and wings face that
you see every time you turn around.
You know, I always go, I'm going to have
to, every time I go to a sports bar,
like I always try to work out before
I go there, you know, burn off,
whatever the fuck I'm
going to eat in there.
Cause I don't want to look at like
those people that are in there.
So that's what I'm saying. There's a
fun way. If you hate the fucking gym,
go get a God damn football dude.
I felt like I was in fifth grade.
Like when I was done, I was looking for
my book bag. You know, it was ridiculous.
Of course, two hours later, I
did not feel like a fifth grader.
I felt like I was 48, but it
was fun nonetheless. All right,
so let's get on with the podcast,
uh, questions and whatnot. Hey,
here's a great thing. If any,
anybody else has like a, um,
had a confrontation, like what
I had. And for whatever reason,
you didn't have the fight.
And you know,
it was funny when I was
saying I was so mad and I say,
I was telling Nia I have to go back there.
When I was dropping her up,
dropping her off, she goes, just
go back and slash his tires,
which really took me back to the whole
revenge thing of how damaging somebody's
car. I literally said that too.
I go, that's the bitch move.
I could slash chuck Norris is tires.
If he wasn't standing
there and ruin his day,
now go back and fight the
guy or just fucking or,
or don't
go back and rip his antenna off like a
fucking pussy fight or don't fight. Oh,
take a walk around a lake
and calm yourself down.
It admit to yourself that you're 41 years
old and you probably had a fucking 50
50 chance of losing the
thing to begin with. Oh,
and I would have been on the ground with
that gravel embedded in the side of my
face. You know, just taking
a boat shoe to the head.
He didn't have on boat shoes. He wasn't
that bad. All right. Okay. Here we go.
Here's a podcast. All right? Last week
I was telling you guys about how I have,
I discovered the magic
word when complaining, um,
to corporations that the
word is a unacceptable.
All right?
And just in case you guys feel that
I don't know what I'm talking about,
which is exactly what you should
feel because I am a moron. Um,
I got this great email from somebody
who, who the fuck is it? God Damn it.
I thought I had it. You
know what? I am the worst.
Why do you guys listen to this
fucking podcast? No, no, no. I know.
I put my hand right fucking here in front
of me. All right. It's back on though.
It's back on track. I actually
got, I actually got a,
an email from somebody who answers the
phones for one of those big corporations.
All right?
And if you want to learn how to do
what I explained it last in last week's
podcast, at least my story of how I went
about, um, getting my money back. So,
so this guy sends me this
really nice. Larry says, uh,
just want to say your podcasts are
fucking hilarious. Keep them coming. Uh,
you should do a show in Omaha
sometime. Uh, that's a rough one, dude.
Omaha's or rough one. I will
at some point. All right.
I just have to get psyched up for that.
The 28 planes I'm going to
have to take to get there.
That's one of those like fucking states.
You have to fly past it to
fly into a hub city, you know,
to finally get there. You know, I'm
flying to Omaha via fucking Tampa.
What? All right. Um, here we go, Bill. Um,
also I wanted to say when dealing
with corporations using the word,
the unacceptable line does work.
I am a support agent for a well
known financial company company.
If someone is continually a pain in the
ass about something and are persistent
about it, eventually they will
get their way. You guys hear that?
I know it's morning. For some of you, you
stir in your coffee. Did you hear that?
If someone is continually a pain in the
ass about something and are persistent
about it,
eventually they will get their way.
Usually as a customer
service representative,
we are encouraged to try and steer
the conversation away from the,
from things like credits and
try to offer other suggestions.
And that's the part where you get mad
because you're not getting what you want.
But that's why you have to keep you
cool. All right. So anyways, he says, uh,
basically we try to bullshit them a
little and try and put them at ease.
Yeah. Lie to them. Okay. But if
a customer is still not happy,
we will give a credit or whatever
you want. As long as it's reasonable,
that's fair. Um, just to get
you off the phone. However,
if you start using profanity,
um, while on the phone call,
chances are we will try and find ways not
to help you or disconnect the call all
together.
Regardless of rules and procedures,
representatives do have the ability
to make judgment calls. Basically,
if you call the customer
service Rep Account,
I will guarantee you they will not help
you stick to using the unacceptable line.
Don't give up and you eventually will
get what you want. You see that people,
there you go.
Now you have the information you need
from a professional rather than some moron
comedian who almost got in a fight
outside of a pancake house. Um,
I actually want another one this week.
All right?
I ordered the NHL package to center
ice package and ask them, hey, now,
so I says to the guy, I just sound
like I was doing fucking Vaudeville.
So I asked the guy, I says, hey buddy,
what's with the chicken
soup? Um, I asked, I asked,
I asked the lady when I ordered it,
does it come with the NHL Channel?
And she says, hold on, let
me check. And she says, why?
Yes, yes it does. And I said,
Dan, you know what? You
got yourself a deal.
I will take the center ice package with
the NHL channel. So she says, okay,
all right. So the boot, the fucking thing
up. And the next day, Lo and behold,
I don't have the NHL channel. So I call
up and what do they say to me? They say,
hey, hello sir, what can I do for you?
And I tell them I deal. And I said, oh,
we actually, she in her notes, she left,
she said that you hung up before the call
was over. And I was like, no, I didn't.
I immediately got pissed who are kind of
fucked his phone call up a little bit.
In the beginning I went the [inaudible]
route, but I didn't say it, but then I,
I got it back on track. I was like,
no, I didn't. And you guys like, well,
according to her notes you did. And I
was like, well, according to my memory,
uh, I was on the phone call and you
weren't okay, so now what? I'm like,
so now what?
She gets to just say something happened,
she writes it down to cover her
ass, you know, and you know,
so that's when I kinda got mad.
But then I was able to bring
it back and just say, look,
the conversation ended with her going,
thank you very much.
Is there anything else I can
help you with? What do you think?
I was halfway through ordering it and she
was gone. Hang on a second sir. Hang on.
I was like, too late. Goodbye.
I didn't do that. All right.
And the guy's like, well, I have to
charge you $5 a month for this channel.
This is, this is like the zero tolerance
I have. I am arguing $5 a month,
which is going to be 30 bucks over
the course of the six month season.
And I'm like, no, I'm not paying that.
Okay. And the guy goes, why? I can't.
I can't give it to you. I don't
know what to do. I go, all right,
well then cancel the center ice package.
And the guy goes, I can't do that. I go,
what do you mean you can't do that?
And he goes,
you can't cancel it once you order it.
I go,
see you mean to tell me
that I ordered something?
It's in what you told me it was,
it isn't and now I can't cancel it
and you can't rectify the situation.
Is that any way to buy a business, run a
business? And the guy's like, whoa. I go,
that's unacceptable.
I want to talk to somebody else so
I get this next guy on the phone.
At this point, I finally calmed down
and I was able to use that line, sir,
I understand you. You know you don't make
the rules. I know this wasn't your call,
but this was the scenario. Okay,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
If he can't give me the channel for free,
like I told him,
you know that it came with the package,
I would like to cancel center rice.
The guy goes, well, I can't do either
one of those, but this is what I can do.
Your DVR costs you 10 bucks a month.
How about I give you three free months,
a DVR that'll be 30 bucks discount
and the whole thing will be a wash.
And I was like, you know what?
You got yourself a deal. Bam.
Two one I'll turn it.
Yeah.
This franchise around a perennial losing
franchise and just like the fucking
saints, I am now a factor.
I am now a fucking factor.
So,
and the last two weeks I got 25 buck
dollars back and I got $30 back.
I am plus 55.
I'm like a Dj that the mush and a a
Bronx tale and I'm finally winning.
Um, plus fee. I say myself. 55 bucks.
Do you know how many tube socks
you can buy with 55 bucks?
It's a lot of fucking socks.
How great do your feet feel when
you got a new pair of socks?
You know I never whistled.
The only time I ever whistle.
Do you ever see me whistle and you know
I've got a brand new pair of fucking
dress socks at tube socks on your feet
take tingle in that right Cleo? Huh?
They tingle.
I was hoping she was
going to make the noise.
Let me see if I can get her mom this week.
You guys haven't heard in a while?
Yeah,
she too busy sniffing the
microphone. Um, anyways. All right,
so let's get on with the fucking questions
here because I got to start wrapping
this up. I'm almost done here. Um, say,
you know what? I feel great right now.
I feel great. I told that fucking
story about the guy at the diner.
I got to laugh at it.
I got to laugh at myself.
I got to be honest that chances are he
probably would have lost the fucking
fight. You know? That's why
I stand up is a great thing.
It's a great fucking thing. You get to
make a complete ass out of yourself.
Fill like a Douche, and then laugh about
it and then you feel better. All right.
Somebody needs advice.
All right. Hey Bill. Ah,
I've got a couple questions and comments
as stories above bar and went out with
this girl last year before I went to the
prom with her. It wasn't really a date,
but it was just a chance to go
out with her and get to know,
to get to know her before we went to prom.
We ended up having a great time
that evening in it and at the prom.
I proceeded to Facebook her a bottle a
week later and asked her if she wanted to
go out again. She basically, she
said she would like to go out again,
but not in a romantic
way. Bombbomb, Boehm boom.
All right. Tonight he took that emotional
kick in the chest. After hearing this,
I backed off and didn't
pursue her for a month or so.
In this time she got a boyfriend,
booboo Badu,
which honestly pissed me the fuck
off as well. It should have. Uh,
I had to talk to her.
Um,
I had talked to her for about a week
before she went out with this guy and when
they finally were officially dating,
I told her I didn't want to cause
trouble and then I didn't want to bother.
She replied by saying that she,
she said she didn't want to go out again
with me is because she was confused
about how I felt and seen when we first
went out before prom that I wasn't
interested. Isn't that funny? After she
said, let's just go out and be friends,
right. Didn't she? Did I already
forget the first part of this?
We saw each other maybe two or
three times again through birthdays,
graduation parties until I went off to
college and she went back to high school.
I am now a freshman in college and have
and have made no friends on account of
my horrific people skills. I feel
like I should go after college girls,
but I can't stop thinking about the high
school girl and feel like she is light
years ahead of these big
titted shallow college girls.
I also feel like she's the first girl
that I ever felt comfortable hanging out
with, although she seems like
she would be a hard girl too,
to woo as she is really intelligent and
I am still am unsure if she likes me at
all.
I was wondering what you think and if you
have any tips on how to really impress
girls besides the cliche confidence
or expensive shit. All right, dude.
You said something back here that really
just rang a bell way saying we use two
or three, two. I am okay. This
sentence right here, dude.
I am now a freshman in college and
have made no friends on account of my
horrific people skills. All
right, dude, that's right there.
That's the money right there. That's
what you need to work on. All right.
Through this girl, still in fucking
high school. You're off at college.
You know what I mean? You are
college. You are in college.
You're living at college.
That is the ultimate fucking
nightclub for the next four years.
It's the greatest nightclub of all
fucking time is living at college.
There's just women everywhere.
That Ron, every fucking floor,
they're in every goddamn class.
You don't even have to, you know,
you don't have to walk into a nightclub
like, hey baby, what's you signed?
Did somebody steal the lights out of
this guy and put them in your eyes?
Right? You don't have to come up with
stupid shit like that. You have a,
you know what I always find it's easy
to pick up women when you're both,
there's a reason that both of
you are there. Like at the gym,
you're both there to work out. You're on
a train. You're both going home. You know,
they don't have their guard up as much
as when they go into the fucking Texas
chainsaw massacre fucking meat locker.
That is a Goddamn
nightclub. All right? So this is
what you need to do. All right.
I think right now you're saying like
you just said that all basically all
college girls are big titted and shallow.
And I think a lot of it has to
do with kind of your, your um,
your,
your hopeless feeling right now that
you don't know how to talk to people and
you don't know how to get things going.
Okay?
That's part of being a freshman
is supposed to seem like a,
a bigger universe than you can handle.
But what you need to do is you need to
work on your horrific people skills,
all right? And it is a skill
that you can work on, all right?
Just like catching a football.
I'm never going to be able to
catch a football like Jerry Rice,
but if I fucking do it enough times,
I can catch the fucking thing, right?
Maybe imitate somebody who's
end zone dance, but you're
going to get in the game.
So what you need to do is understand that
you kind of putting that girl up on a
pedestal, you don't really
know her. And I think the, the,
the comfort of kind of already
having your foot in the door,
I bet you are a lot more comfortable.
I bet you were real comfortable with
the fact that you just kind of being
friends and the pressure was,
was,
was kind of taken off the whole prom
and that type of thing. You're, you're,
you know, you're shy, so you take
like baby steps, you know what I mean?
Instead of taking the big step and trying
to grab her titty on the first date.
I'm joking, but you know what I mean?
So this is what I would do if I was you.
Seriously, I'm kind of fucking around
here, but I know this is like a,
a serious subject for you.
So this is all seriousness.
Just what you gotta do is just you gotta
you gotta Force yourself out of your
shell, you know, I mean,
if you say hello to a girl,
she's not going to punch
you in the face or whatever.
Just really write down on a
piece of paper, what's, what the,
the humiliation or whatever, the fear you
have, what you think's going to happen.
I'm telling you, a lot of times when
you do that and you actually read it,
you realize how ridiculous it is and um,
I'm telling you,
you,
they're never going to be better
looking than when they're in college.
All you guys, you're at your, you fucking,
you write off your right after the
assembly line in Detroit, dude,
fuck that college girl. I mean, whatever,
God bless, I'm sure she's a nice person,
but you got to get in the game and you've
got to start a crushing ass as they
say in fucking old school. That's what you
should be doing there. And, uh, you know,
go out with as many girls as you can see
what you like and mentally becoming up
with the list as far as what's the kind
of girl you eventually want to stay with.
And in the meantime, you bang a
couple of big titted shallow girls.
You always wear a condom.
Unacceptable not to wear one dude
had a fucking worth it. And uh,
you know,
then you got your stories,
then you got your fucking stories
and when you get married, you know,
and he'd go down to the Dunkin donuts
and you want to bang the girl behind the
counter, you know, the temptation won't
be as great because you're fucked.
All those big titted whores at college.
All right, so psych yourself up, dude.
Even tell even like, you know, if
you've got some friends there at school,
just be open a bottle of God. And I got
it. I got no game with girls. Just say it,
get it out there. I got no game with
girls. Come on, help me out. You know,
be a wing man, do something. I got to
get fucking laid. Just get it out there.
I'll tell you as much as cock
block and assholes as guys can be,
when someone's open and
honest about like that.
If I have some guy ever said that to me,
there's no fucking way I wouldn't try
to help him out. So you'll be all right.
Plus it's your first
semester, so you're, you're,
you're making everything bigger than
it is. All right, so there you go.
Let's your missing get out of your
shell and forget about that girl. Okay.
And then, you know what,
after this, you know,
your first two semesters you're going to
come home with a little bit of swagger.
You might be able to bang
that broad are back, uh,
when she's done with her little
fucking pottery class. You never know.
Might come all full circle.
All right,
I only got time for a couple
more questions then I got
to get going here. Um,
Oh, before I get going,
why don't I just do this?
I'll save the questions till next week or
maybe I'll read a couple of quick ones.
Uh, just to let you know, these are
my upcoming gigs for November. Um,
November 6th,
six [inaudible] 2009.
I'm going to be a town hall in New York
City. People tickets are going fast.
All right. And if you act now, I will
throw in a bill. Burke can opener. No,
seriously.
It's 1300 seat theater.
And last I heard we already
sold a thousand and that
was a couple of weeks ago
and um, I just had a flashback
to that Chappelle show. Shit,
a sketch, uh, and word that was weeks ago.
Remember that you slapped me in the face.
He said that was weeks ago.
It's one of the greatest
lines of all time. Um,
all right,
I'm going to be at the town hall in New
York City and the next day I don't have
it on my website. November 7th, 2009,
I'm going to be at Boston
at a guidance Serena,
wherever the Bu terriers play doing the
Denis leary comics come home the 15th
anniversary.
It's going to be great.
Going to get to see a bunch
of friends of mine. Um,
what else do I got? The improv in
Tempe, Arizona. The 19th, 20th and 21st.
And then what else? That's
it. That's all for November.
Then I'm in Cleveland and in Seattle.
And then I do my special.
So please come out. Please continue
to support me. I really appreciate it.
And I didn't have time to
talk about Rick flair videos.
Somebody brought up the ric flair chop
and I had not watched Rick flare in years.
And Dude,
if you really want to laugh,
please go on youtube and just
watch ric flair. Hypen is matches.
It's one he said to that, he said there's
one of him holding up these loafers.
Did I talk about this last week? I
can't remember. Look up ric flair.
Golden Spoon.
There's another one where he tells this
guy that this fucking dude that his
shoes are worth more than his house.
Um, and then there's a great interview,
you know, where he talks
about the movie, the wrestler,
and he just seems like the
greatest guy ever. Like, you know,
his wrestling career is over. He's
not bitter. He's really thankful.
It's just like I,
once again,
I became an even bigger
ric flair fan watching it.
It's ric f a flair.
Ric, the ric flair flop.
Ric flair chops,
ric flair flips.
He's got some of the greatest fucking
videos out there and you just realize what
a true legend.
What a fucking show man.
What a what a just a fucking unbelievable
entertainer athlete and everything
that this guy was in, the fucking things
that he put his body through. Man,
I would love at some point that
guy's ever doing a signing anywhere.
I'm fucking all over it,
you know? Um, that's it.
And that's it for this week.
I hope you guys enjoyed the podcast.
Sorry it was a little bit short.
I'll get to the questions next week.
Hope all you guys have
a, a a good week. Um,
oh man,
there was another great question.
This guy was asking why is tranny
porn on heterosexual websites?
Fuck, I wanted to answer that one too.
I got to get to that one next week.
All right there.
I'm leaving you on a cliffhanger.
I'll talk to you guys next week.
Uh,
that's it.
And don't take any shit
[inaudible]
some
[inaudible].